oh don't you eat the Bluth family  shouldn't footage ruins a champagne  footage you're running for office I'm  really part of the problem Michael is  finally back together oh great get your  stuff let's get out of here well that  didn't last long maybe but maybe we can  figure out where it all went wrong I've  made a huge mistake it seems a lot has  changed over the years I just blew  myself for the first time in five years  well not everything what was it that  brought everyone back together in town  this time but this new new beginning is  different I don't like it because the  Bluths are finally getting the award  they think they deserve family could  give us that we're giving it to  ourselves right it still didn't seem  like would get the boats because nothing  holds you down like family hi I'm  Madeline I came here to save everyone's  Buster oh look who's back  I thought we were supposed to go to the  chair Arrested Development season five  only on Netflix  you